die jungs genetik wir sind der nächste
gast bei klicks um mit dem album dna
sind sie sofort auf platz eins der
charts gelandet und der titel liebs oder
lass es läuft im radio rauf und runter
warum das so ist und wie sie diesen
kometen artigen erfolg geschafft haben
darüber reden wir bei kings und
natürlich über eure fragen genau die am
besten hier unter dem video in die
kommentare postet und wer da rein klickt
habt ihr dann eben auch ein button um
eine video antwort hochzuladen darin
könnt ihr video fragen stellen in eurem
video antworten also fragen an die
beiden jungs ich bin sehr gespannt die
beiden auch ich freue mich riesig ihr
hoffentlich auch und ansonsten was sag
ich immer ach ja bis dann bleibt